おはようございます。はじめしゃちょーです。
今、朝の６時なんですけど、
トミックさんが今寝ていると
で、いつもは、
中入ろう
いつもは寝ているトミックさんに、こう…
派手なドッキリを仕掛けるんですけども、
今回は、派手なドッキリと言うより
寝起きの 朝一の 注意力、警戒心というものを
トミックさんに高めていただきたいなと
名付けて寝起き赤外線レーザードッキリでございます。
まぁ、具体的にはちゃんとした
赤外線レーザーを準備できないんですけども
ちょっと、こういったテープですね
赤いテープをたくさん準備したんで
これを寝起きのトミックさんの周りに
張り巡らせます。
動くと当たっちゃうので
トミックさんの周りに
赤外線レーザーをめっちゃ張り巡らせて
トミックさんが起きた瞬間
目の前は赤外線レーザーだらけだと
果たして彼は
寝起きで注意深く
赤外線レーザーを潜り抜け
安全に起きれるかどうかという
ドッキリでございます
赤外線レーザーは貼るのにたぶん
時間がかかったり音が出ちゃうので
そこで起きるかもしれないのでちょっと怖いんですけど
できる限り
できるだけ貼っていきたいと思います
では行こう
なんで入ってんの？
さぁ、トミックここまで来るんだ！
はっはっは！
５、４、３、
へっへ
トミックさんの寝起きの注意力を上げよう
という動画だったんですけども、
まぁ、ちょっと、いきなりね
正面突破ということで
まだちょっとおつむのほうが
完成していないようでございます
よく頑張ったのぅ
徹夜じゃなかったの
僕の寝起きの強さなめてもらっては困りますよ